hello everybody so a quick introduction
about myself so my name is Oleg zing I
work for a local and i'm working on
analytical solution mostly for the
analysis of analysis of risks in the
financial industry I've got a slight
interest in graph data and I'm pursuing
a master's degree at queen mary on like
a research degree based on on graphs and
stuff so we talked a little bit about
that and i'm also running the the spark
dojo in my spare time in London so if
anybody wants to join us it's a it's a
meet-up so please feel free to sign up
and you receive the invite and you more
than welcome to come in and see it it's
run on a monthly basis so what we are
going to do today so the objective is
try to see how we can use big data
appliances or big data frameworks to
solve kind of business problems and how
do you communicate your results once
you've processed on some data through a
big data framework meaning mostly head
open and spark in order to do that we're
going to use a certain number of tools
which have listed there and that's the
the order in which we gonna we're going
to be exploring the going through the
presentation first one is going to be a
look at the Apache Zeppelin I'm sure
most of you are familiar with Jupiter
and it's kind of an alternative is that
it's like a notebook so we're going to
have a with some slight differences so
we'll see what those differences are and
how you can you can use it for
communicating your your results i will
also be using pi spark obviously within
within Zeppelin and then a couple of
graphic libraries so one is bouquet
which I like a lot for the reason I'm
going to explain but would be also using
some some some others and finally would
be creating an application so
you can actually create like a web app
with with your website with my new web
so your data server being the the spark
application so rather than using a
database you'd be using spark as your
data management system oh yeah so yeah
we obviously all the the code the
presentation and everything is going to
be posted online afterwards I put the
give the link to the organizers and the
idea is that initially I didn't realize
that there would be so many people but I
was I was planning on doing like an ant
on Amazon tutorial so I was going to
give a vm to everybody but I don't see
how I can do that now so but the vm
itself with all the code and everything
would be online and you could be able to
download it so straight onto Zeppelin
Annie and if you got any questions any
time please do ask because I think the
more interactive it is the better no
sorry no
mmm good start
there you
right
you
ok
does anybody know how to stop cherry pie
the services okay
I have to rest on my machine
I've got a conflict in an IP because
they are both using the same IP address
the same port
alright
yes
right can you see something yes should
it be bigger yeah can increase this
yeah that's for me it's okay yeah right
so what were we looking at now it's so
it's a zip line which is as I said a
notebook and it's good similar I mean
lots of kind of similar characteristics
to any other notebooks but one thing
which I find quite interesting to start
with is the fact that it comes up with
lots of different interpreters
integrated so like for example if you
use Jupiter you got to kind of a load or
configure the system so that actually is
able to read our data from from
different sources so our Python or
whatever we're with Zeppelin it comes
actually pre-loaded in a way so if you
look at that's the list of interpreters
that you got by default so spark
obviously because that's what it was
meant to be built for that mark down
that's the shell so you can actually
interact with your linux machine as well
and a list of different interpreters
diagram
right so and so because it's meant to
work for a stock that's like if you type
without making any any comment at the
beginning then the the j-pin assumes
that you are going to write in scanner
so like for example that is in scatter
and you can you just execute and you get
your results so I mean it's as you would
expect by putting like a little dollar
sign percentage sign sorry it that opens
a different interpreter so like for
example here is the shell so that's what
i was saying earlier you would be able
you're able to interact with your linux
machine straightaway and for example if
you want to download something or if you
want to access your hat observer or
something you can do that straight from
from the from the notebook similarly for
titan 4 by spark I just have to put that
dollar sign and then PI spark and then
you are into your pie spark environment
so again the scene and and again just to
execute yeah either you press that or
you you get a shift enter you can do
some interesting stuff with with mac now
so yeah that's the similar approach you
just declare that you want to write
something in markdown and then you can
adjust execute it and you get the mugs
on text so if you want to do a nice
presentation and nice layout to tell a
story you could you could use that but
you don't necessarily have to because
you got the option as well in the
settings to create a title so you could
if you want something pretty simple like
that you can just go and say okay I want
to write a title and it would if you
give you something like that I get the
option to hide or to show the code or
the results for both of them and another
thing that I like a lot is that you can
actually create a web frame so say for
example you've created that graph and
you want to publish it to your colleague
or something you can go there and then
say link to the paragraph and as that
creates like a web frame and then you
can share that that that URL to anybody
and they would be able to access the the
results of that particular cell
obviously that's a graph because that
would be the most obvious reason why you
would want to do that but if it's a
result which is a numerical some some
characters you can well do that as well
just a URL to that little cell within
your notebook ya know if I cause
Zeppelin now I would die because the the
server is no no it would probably
generator I don't know I haven't tried
it but I would think the URL is
generated as you create eat the link so
when I say so when you create those cell
rather if yeah that's so your question
is yeah close it down and I restart
Zeppelin with the URL be still there I
don't think so because well technically
yes but in practice probably not because
you would probably rerun the notebook
and if you rerun the red book I would
thing you change in url so as long as
you don't we run the road book i would
think yes but yeah all right so that's a
couple of feature yes so the next
feature is the graphic and the
visualization capabilities because it's
almost like it sparks equal native what
that what that means is that you can
generate some some data so that's four
that's that example you generate a data
set and that data set is a straight away
organized into a table and and from that
table by default as soon as you generate
some sequel code from sorry the sparks
equal you are able to then have to
create some graphs from it and those are
the default options but some people have
created some extensions so if you are
really interested you can actually go
online and add some some more graphs but
that by default you got so pie charts
what I really called scatter plots and
so on and so forth so that's but yeah so
you can do that wait for that one is not
very relevant yeah all those type of
things
oh yeah that's the next thing which is
pretty cool so here we because I don't
have internet here okay great see if it
works now so let's suppose to go and
fetch a data set from from the internet
and i hope i can get but yeah so what I
wanted to show you here is that not only
are you able to generate some some
graphs but you can make those graphs
interactive so
sorry
I'm very sorry the so what what what I
mean by doing those making those great
graph interactive when so when you
create your script in spark sequel you
just put again another declaration and
then you make that input available and
then the deputy knows to create a field
that when you produce the the graph
becomes a variable and when as you
change the variable the the graph
changes obviously
hmm
right
so if I show this close d
right if I showed the editor here you
see that the dollar sign and then that
me so that makes it a valuable and then
obviously you got the default value
which is a 30 but you could you could
change that and then the graph would be
recalculated I can't do it because I
can't load my my data set but that's the
idea and then the graph obviously will
change because the value would have
changed and obviously if you publish
that on to the internet you can make
those changes as well from the the web
frame so you're here and without having
seen any not a single line of code you
can do the change the value and consider
the results and then you get the option
to create dropdowns rather than then
values that you've created so that's
that's that example so you list the
different values that you want to see in
in your drop-down and that creates a
drop-down menu that's another example
yeah so that's using date d 3 so you can
actually create some some HTML code
straight away inside the interpreter and
that would produce a d3 graph straight
away
and the next example was just a word
count so I think we're going to pass on
that one and then you could see the
results as a as a graph and then so so
that's just an example for a pie spark
so we're going to see a couple of
options just using the basic the default
library you can you can run that code
for example and then the the result
would display underneath in line I mean
as you would expect from from any
notebook anyway again using matplotlib
so again the only thing you got to do is
you just declare that you were being
using pi spark and in that case is only
spark it doesn't not it not even any a
Python in there I know any spark in
there it's pure Piper
and and finally a bouquet and the reason
like the reason why i like both bouquet
a lot is that the output is a
self-contained HTML and it can be
interactive as well so a couple of
example and that everyone so that's
that's the the result of a bouquet
output so you can so what what that is
is yeah so as I was saying I'm doing
some some work on graphs graph data and
one of the data set i'm using for that
is the bitcoin dataset and what we can
see so in a network what you've got is
edges and vertices and what you want to
what you do here is you just try to
figure out how the network evolved over
time by counting the ratio of vertices
of edges over a certain period of time
and so you would be able to generate a
file from bouquet either visualize it
here and create the the link and then
distribute it ouu the result output is a
if i go in there the result output is
hey it's a single HTML file which i've
put into my HT apache web server so that
I could actually redisplay it but
otherwise I could just send the the HTML
file to anybody in an email because it's
it's just a single file and that that
was all generated by by Python and using
pi spark because the data set is in in
spark so I did the calculation of edges
and vertices using spark a pie spark and
then for the rendering and the
collection of the data i was using pure
python
I don't know if there are any in
equation question
right otherwise we can just go back to
the next part so we've we've seen a
we've seen a number of application of
Zeppelin and a couple of library that
you can use using either a spark or PI
spark in order to display or render your
your results and now what we're going to
do is we are going to create a an
application using spark as as a data
management system and I'm Python
obviously so in order to do that we've
got basically three main components a
spark with Vice park in order to kind of
do the processing of the data flask
which is going to create the API and
cherry pie my internet server HTM yeah
internet server the data set i'm going
to use is called movie lens so because
it's a it's a data set that lots of
people use to do some testing on big
data so it's just a some some data but
about films and what we are going to do
is actually create a recommendation
engine yeah using using a spark and
price bar and see how we can actually
retrieve the results from a web browser
it's clear yeah so the first thing you
need to do with Lee is going back to
that diagram is to create my application
in Python or pipe out my recommendation
system so i'm using ml lib which is a
library that would think most people who
are familiar with hawk would know it's
basically a a data science library or a
no it's a bit like psychic rome but for
false fault
and then and then I import obviously
import the data set which includes data
about movies are always saying and the
rating from from different users and
then the idea is to figure out based on
the characteristics that are as an input
which a movie with I recommend to the
user so once i got my data in inside the
system i need to create a query system
or query in order to to to get the
interaction between my my data and and
what the users are looking in the output
of my ml liberal calculation
so what I the the data the data that I'm
coming in I've got sorry coming in is
the sort of the row rating for each of
the movies and then as an input I give
the preference of the user and as an
output it gives me the list of films
that are relevant for that particular
user I don't know if I mean in a way tie
spark is not that different too it's an
API at the end of the day so it's not
that different to scala it's just most
of the function actually the same it's
more the syntax that is slightly
different but at the end of the day it's
all very similar so the name of the
function now is very very similar and
then so once I've done that so I've got
my recommendation recommendation system
running as like independently even at
ice bar I need to create my API in order
to kind of get that interaction between
my browser and in my recommendation
system
so I think the the crunch of it is yet
so the decorator that I would be using
it's that one so that's how i would pass
my instruction from the the aisle that
i'm going to input into my browser and
the end the recommendation engine that i
built earlier so that's that's kind of
the line that you that's the most kind
of the most important in a way and those
are the type of query that i've created
so for each of the query that are in the
recommendation system i need to create a
function that is going to kind of link
up my web browser and my recommendation
system and that there is a just about
creating like a template for the
restitution of the results because at
the enemy i'm getting a json file and
then that's the final kind of step where
I actually create the do like the web
server so that's where I'm going to put
all my HTML data all my gear my web
files in order to get the front and
running and and those are the obviously
the two files that have created created
earlier sorry so that's the one is the
API and the other one is the is the
engine that I've created in the IMP
iceberg
does it I don't know because I've always
been using a flask as an API is kind of
per se but I never used it as a web
server so I'm sure it's possible to do
it as a web server as well no no no no
no yeah that's exactly what it is bad
pony you can do the same in in flask a
family but could you do it straight into
deafening the question is apparently
there is a way of doing it in women
flask itself oh sorry so flask is your
API engine and you need some web server
to kind of make the whole mechanics
running yeah that's um yeah I never
asked myself that question because I
always seen it like that and yeah so the
answer is because that's the way needs
to be because it's just a sausage
machine in between the two in a way that
kind of link up the the user interface
with your application but there might be
some integrated frameworks I don't know
and then here so if you see you have to
do that's that's why you exactly that's
a in a way an answer to your question
because cherry pie would actually
determine the channels and the idea the
the potent and the kind of the
connection that you that you would
require to run euro to plug your yo your
front end the web browser page or HTML
page
but here see here you can see that
you're actually initially in so that
that bit is initializing the the
services from the other two happy
application so the the API as well as
the the spark context
right sue
so yeah that's just give you an idea
about the the 35 I was talking about so
that's the engine that's the dapi and
somewhere you should have a server yeah
the separator so those are kind of the
tree fart that you will need to do that
so we're going to start the the code so
you be using a spark submit which is the
native function to start a spark code in
exec in like in a standalone execution
and you can put a number of options in
particular in that case I'm running on
the single note on my on my my laptop
here but you could specify how much
memory you want to allocate to the
different nodes and so on how many core
do you want to allocate as well that's
where you would actually pass those
information and then here you obviously
you start your your server from there
and it's going to take a little while to
process the data especially on the first
time is it starts a quite a few services
as well as processing the data so for we
have to wait two or three minutes no so
well spark is good that's it that's a
tough question actually so the idea is
that because as park is lazy as as long
as there is a memory in the system each
time you call an object and providing
that day some processing into that that
object then you would be stored in
memory so do from there if there is no
not enough memory anymore when you call
a new one obviously that is going to be
dealt that your previous subject is
going to be deleted right but there are
options to actually keep stuff into cash
the the object that you've created so if
you yet so in order to be more so those
like for example if you have a long
process and then you want you got the
results at the end and that you're going
to query that result repeatedly with the
API for example then it would make sense
to cash that and that would be stored in
memory and you will have to rerun all
the service I mean but here it's doing
far more than that because it's actually
starting the web service at the API it's
starting a spark as well and then it's
running your first set of the code to a
gig recreate that data set that's a
result data set that we are then then
going able to be able to query to get
our recommendation so there is far more
happening than just caching caching
caching some data
but yeah I mean the caching of the the
data in spark is an r3 I mean it's
that's where you connect I mean that's
one of the weight you to really improve
your the code efficiency
and then the reshuffling as well between
the nodes depending on how the type of
query you're going to make knowing how
to kind of order your data set so that
you minimize the communication between
the nodes that that's also crucial
so you're preparing a data set of
users and their recommendations of the
new quarry in the web app or you don't
want to have it that's right so days
okay maybe you can open the air why is
it giving me in here okay um if I open
that file I'm just trying to make sure
so that's the fresca
so that's that's the actual
recommendation engine so as I said you
start with calling the library that's
the one you're going to be you're going
to be using so here the first data set
that you are starting from is a movie ID
the the rating because they're the movie
have been rated and then you get some
sort of average give me one
yeah and then and then depending on what
people have liked in the past test your
input then it gives you a ranking of our
suggestions as a return for that
particular in the video
yeah yeah that's exactly yeah yeah it's
gonna well it's that's the idea I was
getting an error message oh yeah but
let's hope it's working because i think
it's stopped well so we're going to try
to make a query and see what happened
so yeah the first one is always a little
bit slow again for the read because it's
calling a script so here I'm going to
get just that here is there's no
recommendation it's just listing because
I've put one the the top movie in my
database and so that's the very title of
the movie that's the rating of the movie
and that should be a reference i think
the reference number so and as I change
here if I want if I put like five it's
going to give me the top five and it
should be slightly quicker this time
okay yeah thank you so it's calling the
day in the indie application itself
there is a function that does exactly
that it's just a query function and
that's the result of that query function
which is passed through that API code so
you could put pretty much any the idea
is that you could it's translating a
function that you've created in m ali
bin in spark into a web service so what
you query in and what you could get out
of that data set is done to hurry and
and whatever you created
I don't know if we get can try you can
try that one which is a based on movie
ideas I d3 which so let's try
when I was going to return the movie on
North enema hey nice that one is here I
know it's that one either
probably
but yeah how do any questions
sorry just
oh yeah yeah so absolutely absolutely no
no definitely so that but that's that's
the kind of a standard spark pride our
practice right so yay well you so the
okay if you say if you do a linear
regression right that's probably not a
very good example by anyway so you've
got a train training data set and you
want to infer the result of a test set
based on the training that you've done
well you create an object which includes
the parameters of whatever algorithm
that you are trying to use to get the
results on your test set results that
whatever the and and you can actually
aggregate that into a single format so
it becomes an object if you like so say
ah but that's so actually that's that's
a pretty standard way of doing it so say
you got three variables and then as a
result of your training available any
needs to be set at whatever value be at
whatever value would have to percentage
or whatever and see at another value
when you get your new data coming in
depending on the value of those three
variables is going to pay for example if
it's like a same simple sorting
mechanism and you know that you guys so
you would have the type of algorithm
that the value of each variables and
then that would be an input into your
system so that you don't have to rerun
that yeah that's definitively there's
very standard way of doing things